these are dramatic images
images that cause fear and panic this
video was watched on telegram and
twitter
tens of thousands of times the dam named
vopatalchbera
is said to have broken but that is false
i'm standing in front of the dam and as
you can see it's not broken
the video actually shows a flooded mine
in indian which is more than 100
kilometers from here
there were reports of other broken dams
as well but most of them
were wrong this was the case in zinfish
the fire brigade had to drive through
the town and calm people down
even the police were warning online
against the fake messages
and that despite the catastrophe being
bad enough already
more than 170 people lost their lives in
germany alone
many more are still missing and the
damage is in the millions
the fake news caused further damage it
panicked people and stirred up anger we
will show you some examples but above
all
how to spot them for example this image
that went viral on social media
a car is drowning in the floods and in
the back window there is a sticker with
a curse word
directed at greta toonberg
if you look closely you see the images
manipulated
a reverse image search reveals the truth
the photograph was originally published
in the german newspaper built
without a sticker on the car
photographer david young confirms
the picture has been photoshopped many
people were fooled by it
even a big environmental protection
movement so be careful with the content
you share
many were speechless in this case a fake
police car was making its rounds
through the flooded area
we could locate the area as batnoyna
availa
a lot has been destroyed there and in
the case of the situation
many confused the car for a real police
team
it made announcements that the number of
rescue workers were being reduced
falls as was confirmed by the police in
koblenz
according to our research there are
several such fake police cars in germany
and these appear again and again in
connection with the lateral thinker
scenes in germany
which is actually known for protests
against the covet restrictions
or the case of the hydroelectric power
station brown zimbach
at the austrian german border here a
user was claiming that
all the locks had been opened and masses
of water were flowing towards the
southern german city
of paso
the video actually does show the
hydroelectric power station brown or
zimbach
the clip reached a lot of people on
telegram and caused worry
but fact is the hydroelectric power
station does not have the function of a
dam
in case of rising water level the water
has just got to flow through it
so the locks were not opened recklessly
in this case
[Music]
and these fakes even took it a step
further with calls for donations
imposters misused the willingness to
help by the population
so how do we know if a call for donation
is trustworthy
watch out for an official stamp of
approval like this one in germany
and also look at the person and
organization very carefully
have you spotted fakes regarding the
flooding in germany
write them down here or send us an email
to factchecking
dw.com